and here is tony gonzalen
who's got good numbers and great stuff
acuna strikes out that was a clinic
freddie freeman who went deep in the
first inning last night off walker
bueller how about back-to-back
strikeouts for godzilla if he could
strike out the side here in the first
inning
that is up the middle diving stop taylor
gets up close he
got him to end the inning
what a play by chris taylor
getting the speedy ozuna at first
diving behind the bag on the third base
side of second he's able to get up throw
from his knees ghetto zuna what a first
inning for the dodge that's exactly what
anderson was looking for strikeout with
the runner at second now one away 1-1
pitch is skied
out behind the second base position
comes in calls off albee's and has it
for out number two runners at first and
second for will smith
that is hard hit what a pick
austin riley and then the wide throw but
freeman able to keep his foot on the bag
the call is out
you never know what's going to happen so
continue the play
and he just got up to make sure but what
a play what a pick that ball was a
rocket hit by will smith freddy does
this a lot he positions himself so
wherever the throw is
he can make the necessary a movement
with his feet here's a one-two to seeker
[Music]
another strikeout of corey seeger after
a walk to bets and there are two down in
the inning bases loaded two down looking
to deliver for the dodgers anderson
teals and a grounder to third getting
the high hop is riley into the bag
to end the inning well this is where you
trust freddy freeman as your best hitter
and you send
ronaldo cunha on the pitch
trust that freddie's not going to expand
the zone
[Music]
he does not run and this one is driven
into right
good bye
freddie freeman goes deep
and it's a two-nothing atlanta lead here
in the fourth inning
a guy who has spent
over half his life in the braves
organization 11 years in the big leagues
first lcs and he's played two games has
two home runs
ian anderson this post season 15 and two
thirds innings pitched
no runs
one on one out brings up christian
pacquiao
three two pitch grounded
that's fair down the line
[ __ ] over to dig it out marcakis will
be brought around third seeger throws
safe and it's three nothing
the rookie
finds daylight between turner and the
line and the kid delivers here in the
fifth pedro baez takes over
with the left-handed hitting freddie
freeman
at the plate batting with two on here
and he grounds one through the hole
into that center field flying to
[Music]
he stays on the bag another rbi for
freeman and it's four to nothing atlanta
and the bases are loaded with one out
for darnold 3-2 pitch
is in the dirt that will force homer run
five to nothing atlanta on a walk and an
rbi to travis dorneau and everybody
moves up to bring in all these
three two and that's driven in the air
to center
back is ballinger with a leap a grab
tagging and scoring is freeman
and it is a loud long sack fly off the
bat of aldi's to make it six to nothing
braves here in the fifth and it's two on
with two out
that's in the air to right long run on
the one fair ball
and it takes a bounce up into the seats
for a ground rule double
another run on the board it's seven to
nothing atlanta here in the seventh two
on and one out
seeger hits one in the air to left
center this ball is crunched at the wall
it's gone
corey seeger puts the dodgers on the
board
it's 7-3
and there is life
for los angeles here in game two
exactly what they needed aldi's had a
nice night homeward last night he's got
two singles in sac fly tonight
shoots one into left center field watch
out tomlin it's coming your way
that's twice that's melanson he's caught
two
in two games
[Music]
has hit
two in two games
yeah that's the last hitter he's gonna
face and either gets him out or melanson
comes in the game two-and-oh here muncie
[Applause]
this is an eight to six
ball game
onesie touches one off
here in the ninth
working in a hurry melanson brings it
and a ground ball hard hit
all these knocks it down but it's safe
hustling all the way
the tying run
will come to the plate
and it's cody bellinger
[Applause]
that is driven into the corner
it takes a bounce up against the wall
smith is going to come all the way
around digging for third bellinger and
the tying run is 90 feet away
hard hit third baseman
makes a play and that's austin riley to
end the night what a game what a finish